hello everyone and welcome to a really
exciting game from the 2019 women's
feeder Grand Prix
it's humpy Canelo vs. Ali in a car since
kaya and it's well it's one of those
games that you will want to show to your
friends the friends at the bar and the
library now this is the women's feeder
Grand Prix is also this is a first of
four stages that will determine two of
the well two of the participants of the
2021 women's candidates tournament so
basically this is a also two as a World
Chess Championship cycle but the game is
really awesome so let's just dive
strenght straight into it
canary with the white pieces opens with
D for Carson sky goes Knight to f6 with
c4 e6 Knight to f3 and of course d5 we
entered the Queens gambit declined with
nice the c3 and now Bishop to b4 the air
goes in defense and Bishop to g5 now we
have aged 6 and now Bishop captures on
f6 you could also go h4 of course but
nowadays Bishop captures on f6 is the
more popular line we have Queen captures
on f6 and here if you remember we've
covered it too not so long ago Dingley
ran against onigiri being played Queen
to a4 here in the singled cup won a very
nice game against Gary and well it was
just a very nice game but here we have
III it's a more of a timid approach we
have castles and now rook the c1 so this
is all these are all the main line moves
and here D captures on c4 which is very
interesting we always mention how black
will always want to wait for white to
develop the light square bishop and only
then capture the force why to lose the
tempo but here D captures and c4 is d is
the strongest move recommended by the
internet and everyone plays it in this
line probably the reason why you don't
want to wait for white to develop light
square bishop is is due to the fact that
you want to play c5 for example if you
play
c5 now would then do my can for example
AC captures and d5 pawn captures and now
you have this pawn here on d5 after D
captures on c5 there's a double attack
on it now so for example you cannot
recapture if you recapture just Knight
captures here opens up an attack again
the bishop here and well someone
probably analyzed the thoroughly and
that's why he captures and c4 in this
line you don't wait for the bishop to be
developed Bishop captures on c4 in the
now c5 now it's a different story D
captures does nothing really as there's
nothing for white to gobble up on d5
white castles and now see captures on d4
before capturing you go Knight study for
with an attack on the Queen and Queen to
e7 just to show an example it is
possible to defend your pawn for example
Queen g6 you go after the knight and
prepared to capture here but it's a it's
a really dangerous position which can go
really really wrong for black for
example Bishop d3 you put a bishop on
this diagonal that the Queen occupies
not f5 night g3 and okay now you can
grab the pawn not allow white to
recapture but then white plays Queen b3
puts the Queen and this really nice
diagonal pins the e6 pawn also the
bishop on b4 is under attack and if you
go it captures an f2 with Czech grabbing
another pawn rook captures and Bishop to
e7 seems like everything is fine but
it's really not because white can go and
Knight captures on f5 and here black
will just fall apart there's there's not
much to do here you can't even give up
the rook for for a knight and Bishop
because white first plays rook captures
and see it with check for example King
gauge 7 now Knight d4 with a triple
attack against the rook here also the
rook cannot move because you lose the
Queen width check you can't develop
anything this is just completely lost
for black so this is one point you do
not want to defend this guy here so
Queen back to e7 and now e captures on
d4 just recapturing the pawn rook to d8
nicely developing the rook and the D
file and now Queen to c2 the queen and
rule battery works nicely now on the
open sea file Bishop to d7 Carson sky
wants to play Bishop to c6 the cause of
the Queen's and rooks influence on the C
file and also put the bishop on this
wonderful diagonal with
a3 pushing the bishop back Bishop to a5
and bow even b4 we have Bishop to b6
and now look after a one this is a very
important move for this game and you
should remember the
rook to e1 move but okay Bishop the c6
now those bishops are nicely placed the
bishop pair is working beautifully here
but still black has to develop the
knight and the rook and has to figure
out a way how to do it with rook C back
to d1 putting another defender to the d5
d4 pawn and here you have to your spidey
sense has the tingle here there is no
way around it
if you don't do something then you have
to feel this White has extreme attacking
potential here you should play something
like Bishop captures I need for the
Queen cannot I mean for example Queen
captures now Knight to d7 you prepare
Knight to f6
and now after for example even give up a
pawn and then rook c8 and black will
have black will have a playable game but
here black played the Queen to c7
probably with the idea that if white
plays a slow move like h3 or something
then you go Bishop captures now rook has
to capture because the Queen is stuck
guarding the dish appear for example
rook captures and now you've got nice d7
the bishop still cannot move the Queen
and c2 is undefended so there's that so
after this Queen to c7 move which was
played in the game this doesn't work but
why doesn't work feel free to pause the
video while I give you a couple of
seconds and try to figure out why this
doesn't work so for those of you who
were able to do it
congratulations you have just found the
winning move of a game that you will be
showing to your friends at the bar and
the library and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
Knight eat g5 that's right it's really
an awesome move and I saw it just 24
tweeted this position when it happened
and I was like mm very nice and I
thought when I saw the position okay
obviously Queen h7 is a threat if you
captured the other night takes this
guy's place but I thought if Bishop
captures on f3 then there is nothing
there Queen h7 okay King f8 that there
is no continuation but was I wrong
so let's first just show what happens if
you capture the night if you capture the
night King f8 you don't want Queen h7 to
come with the check you want to have a
safe square for a king queen to h7 and
now Bishop to d5 blocking off one of the
attackers also putting more defense to
the e6 pawn
but now Bishop captures rook captures on
d5 and now Queen to h8 check King e7 and
now Queen captures on g7 and now there's
really not much you can do here the f7
pawn is threatened you have to capture
here check King f8 and now d5 and here
Black is just without moves once the
position opens up the two rooks will
become extremely strong Queen h6 will be
dangerous
you cannot care sorry you cannot capture
otherwise Queen h6 followed by rook to
e8 will be made you could try to develop
some pieces but that won't really help
you you're just gonna capture here still
there's nothing to do pawn captures
you're just gonna get Queen h6 check
King g8 you're gonna capture here with
check King back Queen h6 with checking
g8 and now rook to e7 threatening mate
here and there's not all that much to do
you can play Bishop captures on f2 but
white will just ignore you for example
came to h1 and now if Bishop to b4
blocking let's say this Square for some
reason you can still just go Queen h7
followed by Queen Queen to f7 mate or or
you can even just make fun of black and
even capture that Bishop as the C 1
square is covered by the White Queen so
there is no back rank mate for black but
yeah just one of the nice things that
can happen if H captures and g5 so of
course the black played Bishop captures
on f3 and this is what I thought when I
saw the position here there's no
continuation here I mean what do you
play ok Queen to h7 was played King to
f8 but what now
I guess you recaptured the bishop and
the game is over but it's not over and
for those of you who also found this
move then you are really I'm gonna
impress your friends at the bar in the
library because here white played rook
captures on e6 just just uh you know it
also add additional you know info the
shop captures and Knight captures and e6
also wins for white but rook captures on
e6 forces resignation because now the
e-file is closed the hunt the black King
cannot get to e7 and Queen h8 will be
made so if you play F captures on e6
it's also just a very nice forced mate
because you don't go for this check and
the Queen rather you just go for a nice
mating sequence Queen
check King g7 Queen captures on g7 trip
King the sex Queen to e5 check King to
e7 and now Queen captures any sex with
check we have King to f8 Queen g8 with
check the bishop nicely defends the
Queen over there King to e7 Queen f7
check King 36 and now Quinta east sex
will be made and and that's pretty much
it
so after rook captures an e6 Aldina
Carson sky decided there was no point in
continue in this game and this is how
this beautiful miniature happened I'm
just I'm just super excited that this
game you know took place as it's it's 20
moves really a wonderful miniature so
III do hope you enjoyed it and thank you
to everyone who suggested it as it's a
very nice game so I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Alex lahrman
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot that really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
video serum think of for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the feed a
World Cup may be such a nice game arises
we're gonna check it out as well
checking up on your suggestions as usual
and so on so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day